okay let's go to the phones and see
what's on folks Minds today a 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 is of course our number let's
start with our caller from the 9 1 9
area code who's calling today from 9 1 9
or actually that may be country code 91
is that is it cut this country code 91
make more sense hello
country code yes that is you who's this
oh yeah
India okay very good what's on your mind
yeah so you know mother
the black man who's had their police put
his knee on and you know he was killed
on video yes and you know what what
happened was teachers got fired do you
think there's any way that eventually
will ever come to a place where these
people will actually be accounted for
their crimes well you know the I'm
actually watching a couple of
documentaries right now about the
difficulty of getting guilty verdicts
for murder and manslaughter for police
officers who kill others in the line of
duty and I mean listen the way our
system works is that you need to be
convinced of guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt and one of the things about our
system is when you are a police officer
and part of your job is to assess
so-called threats and you use deadly
force if you determine it necessary it
is very easy for a good lawyer to
introduce some doubt and that according
to our system reasonable doubt is all
you need for not for a not guilty
verdict and unfortunately you know even
pointing out this is a trained police
officer who does this for a living that
is the basis for arguing we probably
should doubt that they just went out and
committed murder as we would call it and
so it's a structure
reality of our system and that's what
makes it very difficult to get guilty
verdicts for police killings yeah so
weird so there's a video of this kind
like in individual you can see them
crush this man's head and even I know
that user is going to get fired yeah and
a bunch of people writing with the same
feeling people writing to me saying that
you know the the the father and son duo
who killed Ahmad our Barry are unlikely
to be found guilty and yeah I mean I
don't think people are wrong in erring
on the side of that being the most
likely outcome it's horrible yeah um so
the DOJ is you know a busy place
did I not investigate slander now this
is all Obama gating how effective you
think is that for these Republicans when
they're talking with finding debating
fight in it like you think it's
effective as effective as Benghazi no
well no I don't believe it will be and
part of the evidence is that the
discussions of Obama gait are already
starting to fade I may be wrong but a
couple days ago I checked for Google
searches for it and they're rapidly
diminishing so I think the fact that
you're hearing less about it already is
a sign that they realize it's not gonna
have the cachet of Benghazi but I
wouldn't be surprised to see them try to
focus on hunter Biden that may be one
that they're gonna really go all-in on
in the next couple of months we'll see
yeah I can't I don't want to see so much
discernment information in November sir
I can't even imagine yeah it's gonna be
ugly all right my friends great to hear
from you I think that's the first caller
we've ever gotten from from India I love
it